are disney looking to reboot another
great sci-fi series is space above and
beyond about to come back
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
move your channel
so i have a source that i talked to
about lots of up-and-coming projects and
this person has been working quite
closely with disney plus he's been
talking to me about firefly and a
potential reboot of that series a series
that was taken away from us too soon but
he's been telling me that they keep
trying to do a pilot or um a idea of
what they would want to do with firefly
and it keeps failing they've apparently
done it three or four times now and
every time they do it just doesn't work
it's not right so it keeps getting
knocked
back but disney plus are desperate to
get something from this big collection
of intellectual properties that they
bought when they bought fox and to bring
back something for disney plus they are
desperate for more content on disney
plus and they would love a new big
sci-fi franchise to really get onto the
channel because at the end of the day
the sci-fi stuff that they've got so far
has worked really really well
star wars marvel so on and so on and
they want more
so
they've took space above and beyond off
the shelf and dusted it off and are
considering a reboot of that series a
reboot that might call them a downside
quicker than firefly which they just
can't seem to get their head round so
what are we actually looking at for this
well
the space above me on series if you
never watched it around for a year it
was produced between hard 8 pictures and
20th century fox and i have to say it
was quite a complicated series there was
lots going on
we had
the main story that the chigs this alien
species suddenly attacked our own um
earth colony our first outside of our
solar system earth colony that humanity
didn't have faster than light technology
but there were um wormholes that you
could use and you could predict where
they were and you get places
now these chigs had basic ftl technology
not very good they're supposed to only
be like a decade or two decades ahead of
humanity um but for some reason they
attacked us and
they defeated us badly the entire first
series really is just getting just our
asses handed to us over and over again
in military conflicts they keep our
flanking us they keep defeating us
really badly they create the new united
nations which was made up of the navies
like from the royal navy we had we the
british had spaceships up there and the
american navy
if you do like the content by the way
guys please consider hitting the
subscribe button consider sharing the
video wherever the hell you like him
hitting that like don't hit the down
that doesn't help anybody
also
consider becoming a fully fled
sidetracker hit the join button all
these little things they really help me
to keep the channel going in and then
those few little pennies that basically
means the wife will let me keep doing it
the series was based around the 58th
space aviator cavalry i am your senior
drill instructor i am here to turn you
slimy civilian cesspool parasites in the
united states marine corps space
aviators invoking bowel wrenching fear
into the dark hearts of your enemies why
are you here sir to find a direction sir
an erection are you lost sir i suffer
from a sense of disconnection answer the
question sir yes i am sir well do i look
like a road map to you sir no sir
i am a road map and these hammerhead
spaceships that i just love i just love
those sa-43 hammerheads i thought they
were great and every great sci-fi series
should have iconic ships the saratoga
the space carrier that's in the series
again is absolutely phenomenal beautiful
series i hope they bring elements of
those back um i keep talking about how
like they're doing a book rogers reboot
i really want to see the thunder fighter
back this is the same for that the
hammerhead was a great looking ship and
they've got to bring it back
but there's lots of other stuff going on
in space above and beyond that i also
want to bring back
and there was before the series a
conflict between humanity and um our own
creations a bit bit bastard galactic of
this and we've actually created a
species of androids
called the silicates and um there had
been a conflict between them there were
rumors throughout the series actually
that the silicates are the ones that had
contacted the chigs because um they were
still fighting sort of a guerrilla
warfare on earth and that the silicones
found this is a way of sort of like
wiping out you know the enemy of my
enemies my friend sort of thing
let us
as we say ambassador take your lead
toward an understanding
every person on earth would like to hear
why hundreds of frankly
innocent lives were taken by the attack
on the vesta and telus colonies
asked mr wayne
he knew
we were there
[Music]
the only thing i know now what i knew
before
is the chigs capacity for lies you had
the subplot of the in vitrios which were
um genetically engineered humans that
were designed and grown basically were
born at like 18 years old that they were
used to um grow the ranks of the army
and this conflict against the silicates
and now obviously in the conflict
against the cheeks they adorable
nicknames from the like tanks which is
quite nice you know because i'm stronger
than everything and nipple necks
not so nice but
that created a really fun um
layers to this series throughout it and
you know lots of tension and drama
between the main characters that we saw
in this marine corps this cavalry
division that we see so much of and and
that some of them were in vitro some of
them were humans and that conflict there
and but also then
they did a beautiful job in this series
that we never really saw what the cheeks
were we never knew what the chicks and
motivations were why they were attacking
us we didn't see a chig actually until
the very end of the series we got to see
little bits about the cheeks as the
series went through for example how the
chicks would dig up
our dead bodies and then dismember them
and the idea being that actually they
believed because they've seen little
bits of our pop culture that they
believed humans after they died came
back as zombies
and would keep on fighting and they'd
misunderstood our culture and then
believe that to be true i love little
details like that um and and i just
think there's just a clever element to
the series the only really proper sci-fi
fans may be appreciated
honor
dedication
sacrifice
these are just the words they used
to get you here
now the only word that means a damn to
you is life
so is this a series i want to see come
back well a modernized version of the
series oh hell yeah like i said this
series was seriously ahead of its time
if streaming services had existed then
in 1995 when the series was made i
genuinely think it would have been a
much bigger success than it was and i
don't think it would have been cancelled
the dream
it's inevitable
the same dream
this show was actually penciled in to
complete at least five series so they
had a storyline idea that covered at
least five series so there's plenty of
material there for them to get stuck
into we had a series of 23 episodes
already and again lots of storyline
there even though i do think in a new
streaming service we'll only see 10 or
12 episodes i think we'll see a far more
focused story um
beautifully made i should imagine
because they're spending a lot more
money on cgi and things like that
nowadays than they did then um but even
though this this series was beautifully
made i think there is so many different
aspects of this series though that they
could get stuck into
for example um the aerotech subplot
aerotech in this
universe is sort of like google
or microsoft or spacex they're one of
the biggest industrial military
complexes on the planet at the time they
make all the weapons they build the
hammerhead and so on and so on um in
this so we find due in the first series
we found out that and they were actually
potentially aware of the cheeks and
didn't tell anyone they they had very
much a corporate attitude rather than
saving lives
and they were actually in league with
the this new un um and oh there's just
so much conspiracy and political
intrigue as well which is a really
interesting subplot
so much to get into the series you can
tell i think by how i'm talking that i'm
very excited about this it's this this
was one of my favorite shows at the time
i was gutted when it got cancelled and
because i just could see where it could
go i should also say the original series
in the uk at least is available in
disney plus so you can go back and watch
it i think the fact that it's on disney
plus should be a bit of a hint that
actually this is a show that they are
seriously thinking about bringing back
and if we are to believe my source they
cannot figure out how to bring firefly
back properly but this they can get
their heads around
so we might actually see it sooner
rather than later please give us a
comment and tell me exactly what you
think is this a show you want to see
come back do you think it has potential
also if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit the bell
notification thumbs up thumbs down
doesn't help anybody and if you do like
the material i produce then please
consider becoming a fully fledged
sidetracker hit the join button every
little contribution helps me to keep
this channel going
as always guys please stay safe and i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you